hi my name is Peter Lenz
I am as I just said a geospatial analyst
at distillery I am a member of our data
science team I am loathe to actually
call myself a data scientist because
unlike the other DS members who have you
know stats and are backgrounds in
physics and nano molecular machines I
took Latin I'm an AI I studied maps I
didn't learn Python until I was in my
twenties which is really interesting
because I end up at a company that's
kind of the definition of big data and
clicky clicky maybe yes wow that's not
supposed to do go back back this is why
you don't buy a clicker the day before
at distillery we're a programmatic ad
company we every time you're seeing an
ad on the internet it's an auction and
there are dozens of companies that in
real time are bidding to show an ad to
you and we figure out how much we're
going to spend and if we even want to
show you ad using machine learning
algorithms and one of the inputs to that
is geospatial data we have every day
about 80 billion transactions a large
percentage of those are going to be
those bid requests that are that are
auction opportunities one of the unique
things about distillery is that we
license a huge amount of non ad
monetized data source seeing all these
advertisements we're also seeing web
pages we're seeing apps that don't have
any ads and we're seeing a lot of data
that we use to build our algorithms each
one of these bid requests we have 200
millisecond timeout and of that about
half of it is actually used up in
transit time so we really only have
about milliseconds to apply I think last
time I checked 50,000 or so machine
learning models that we can apply for a
different different
of ad campaigns audiences this is all
anonymized by the way we've actually
been called Boy Scouts in the industry
because we really do believe in
anonymization every day we're gathering
there about 15 terabytes of data and
that flows into our 20 petabytes Hadoop
data store when I was collecting these
numbers which are really really
impressive to me our sis offs people
actually told me we used to be the
largest Hadoop cluster on the East Coast
we've since been eclipsed by a couple of
big banks downtown but we're certainly
one of the largest and that spread
across 2,500 servers which I
occasionally used to do adding um hey
why is my clicker not working you know
what screw the cracker clicker so I want
to talk to you guys about practical
things this is the data engineering
track you are the guys who are playing
around with the data that we're pulling
in you're making it flow places so that
I can analyze it and in my history
playing around with data I've learned
that a lot of the time you guys treat it
just like it's any other type of data
it's an integer it's a float it doesn't
matter we play with those all the time
I'm here to tell you that that's not
actually the right idea spatial data is
a special class of data it is literally
real-world data you need to understand
what it means where it came from how it
was collected before you can have it
flow into your data stores so let's just
take one quick example this is real data
that came out of our system about a
month ago these guys right here I
shouldn't have done that I'm not
athletic that data right there is real
lat/longs that are flowing to your
system where app operators app
developers have transposed latitude and
longitude there's an entire phantom
United States down here in Antarctica
where the Penguins are playing with
snapchat in Pokemon go you can just see
north of Madagascar that's the United
Kingdom
I've corrected this turned rotated it
here you can see how it perfectly lines
up this is just transposing two numbers
and by transposing those two numbers you
had a 10 that was in kilometer error in
your system this is fat
you need to know what geospatial data is
let's let's actually get down to brass
tacks the first thing you need to ask
yourself is how was my data collected
you probably think oh it's a CSV or it's
some kind of stream of data that's
coming in no we're gonna go back a
little bit farther like I said this is
real world data this world this is the
earth it's roundish that roundish is
actually a huge huge issue you see when
we were kids we're told the Earth's a
sphere
it ain't a sphere it's if you went to
college and I did you can learn that
it's called an oblate spheroid if you're
one of the cool kids in college now you
learn that something called a geo it'd
which means something that's shaped like
earth and is a neat tautology and
completely worthless
it's an oblate spheroid that's a thing
that's kind of round and at a micro
scale that kind of roundness is really
easy we call mountains and rivers oceans
the Brooklyn Navy Yard but there's an
even bigger macro scale of non roundness
you see and this is gonna be a big
number I like this because this is a
conference talking about nanoseconds 4.4
billion years ago the earth got hit by
another planet it's about the size of
Mars it's a rogue planet this is the
only photo of a collision of two planets
you're gonna see at this conference
today and we're part of the galaxy
called the stellar crease where stars
are born our star had just been born
there and which stars are born they
throw off garbage not like you know
candy wrappers planets it's a rogue
planet thrown off by some other star
about the size of Mars smashes right
into the earth the earth is cooling down
but at the instant it hits it remounts a
shock wave flies through the planet it
flings off a whole bunch of debris for
those of you and your computers you can
look up more details it's called the
great impact
hypothesis so and this debris will
eventually become the moon believe it or
not but what's important is that it
warps the shape of the planet Earth
we're not evenly round depending on
where you are on earth we need lots and
lots of different models data scientists
love models models of roundness so let's
take a look at a quick cartoon to
illustrate this this is a cartoon of the
earth I swear it's not a potato we have
here two datums a datum is the is a
model of the roundness of the earth and
the exact definition of that roundness
this these dashed lines we call those
reference ellipsoids you can use that
next time you have a triple word score
and Scrabble it doesn't matter which
ones they are but they're there these
are nad27 we love initializing things in
geography in edie 50 you can see that
this dark bold dashed line but this is
our nad27 a datum that you would use in
north america it use really closely to
our cartoon earth in the area labeled
North America edy 52 excuse really
closely to the curvature of the earth of
the fake earth year and the area labeled
Europe you kill we would never use a
European datum in North America you
would get a scale ever a huge error you
would be off by kilometers per haps and
there's lots and lots and lots of these
datums because the earth is rounded lots
and lots and lots of ways this is just a
screenshot I took out of probably arcmap
i have a lot of different GIS programs
if they're a while they all look alike
you can see some of these are really
really specific old egyptian old
Hawaiian Oahu in general as a geographer
you want to use a datum that represents
the roundness in a small an area it's
possible back when I was working for
engineering companies including working
on this whole Brooklyn Navy Yard project
I would use the New York City's plane
which describes the roundness of the
earth in New York City and yes you have
to consider this North is slightly
different the South southern part of
Manhattan that it would be at the
northern part of you hit Manhattan
you would never think that it's been
Hatton it's 20 miles long it matters if
I was pulling in data from Long Island
well that would be in a completely
different datum the Long Island state
plane so you're thinking okay whatever
these are engineering things I don't
work with this if you're pulling in any
kind of geospatial data it's in a datum
and you need to know what it is we're
kind of lucky in our industry data that
we look at is usually at the level of a
country or the entire world if we're
working in North America it's probably
going to be in one of those nad datums
that the latest one is called nad 83
from 1983 our distillery we're working
with cellphone data it's almost always
in a Stannah datum called wgs84 world
geodetic standard 1984 which is
worldwide remember I stole it told you
that you use try to use a small a datum
as possible well that's a datum for the
entire world and quite frankly it sucks
but it sucks equally across the entire
world is an equal opportunity offender
and that's really good because if I were
to use different kinds of datums I could
get an error like this so these black
lines these represent ground truth and
that's a term of ours that are in the
geography industry means the real thing
because anything you collect it's wrong
in some way it's biased ground truth is
the real thing
on the earth our one-to-one model that
we can never ever quite get to this data
was collected in one datum I don't know
let's say it's wgs84 and we're and we've
and we have a second set of data which
has been collected and I don't know it's
Manhattan and it's been collected and
Pitcairn Island which is a tiny little
island at Pacific Ocean we have hundreds
of meters of ever here and just you know
real life things I've seen data
companies which pull in data its
geospatial data they don't think in the
slightest about what datum it's in it's
perfectly good it's great data it's
really really accurate because they
didn't think about what datum it's in
they have automatically created errors
in their system that can be kilometers
and it's a really hard bug to actually
say
because there's there's no code error
here it's an error in the way of
thinking it's an era of actually working
with the data and understanding it the
errors here not in our JavaScript or if
you're working JavaScript with
geospatial data god bless you so you're
probably wondering okay how did I
actually collect this data well the way
you do that is you go out and you
collect it manually you go out there in
the old days you would go and you'd find
some reference point on the earth we
call it a survey marker they look like
this you can actually still write to the
the US Geological Survey give them that
that a code there 53 WSM and they'll
tell you everything about this when it
was collected what the temperature was
you know was it cloudy will still have
all sorts of different pieces of
information about collecting this data
get back to you know that point would be
right about here you see there's a line
there's a brass marker at the bottom of
it you this is a known point on there
someone has already collected this
information I'm going to measure the
difference between this in some other
point you see there's actually a chain
right here you know your marble
notebooks you had in elementary school
they had all sorts of weird measurements
order them was a chain you're a hogshead
that's the chain of the chain in the
back of your book it's actually a
measurement that's used in spatial
thinking by the way the protagonists of
this incredibly culturally insensitive
painting that's George Washington that
George Washington before his father of
his country you know rebel general this
is how he actually made his money he was
a geographer and you're wondering hey
that guy was really that was really old
stuff we have all sorts of satellite
sensing that's still the best way to
collect that data someone goes out there
the only thing that's different is that
little machine there has a laser instead
of that chain but you know what it's
still measures and chains even better if
you just look under here
you can still see a string with a brass
weight at the end which finds this cross
in the middle of that at that point
which is the exact known point we have
never improved
on the technology of brass weight on a
cotton string to find this unknown point
on the earth just ain't gonna happen
okay so you're saying I have a datum
I've collected my data right I know
about it let's put it on a map I've
asked you to think about how you
actually create that map so in the very
beginnings the early days of geography
we just drew stuff we just put it down
on a map this is what's called a poor
Tolan chart it's from the 1300s all of
these little lines those are actually
the names of ports in the the
Mediterranean Sea we've got these lines
they're called wind roses they basically
represent the wind comes out of this
direction sometimes and sometimes it
comes out of this direction there's no
rhyme or reason to this map it's just
stuff that's drawn some of its the scale
I actually take the back none of this is
the scale it's just kind of stuff and it
didn't matter if you were sailing from
Rome to Cairo you're only traveling at
the speed of the wind and the surf and
you'd adjust along the way and you know
if you by the time you make it to these
other Shore you're a hundred kilometres
off does it matter
I'll make it there next week it's fine
no problem
but as our world got bigger we had to
start thinking about how to actually
draw things that made sense in relation
to other things we started to create
what I call projections a projection is
taking that data that was collected in
some datum it's in a three-dimensional
space and putting it down onto a
two-dimensional chart this is about 150
years later and we've gone from wind
from our directions being based on the
wind we have the beginning of a grid
system things here are more or less in
in scale to each other
we're getting more professional fast
forward you know a couple hundred years
and we have thousands of projections
this is my tool box as a geographer
every single one of these projections
has a particular job you know I actually
do a lot of calculations of des figuring
out distance and lambert equal area
conic but it looks weird it's got this
curvature to it so I actually do the
display
Mercator maybe I want a particular
projection that shows things in scale to
one another maybe I want one that's good
for navigation there's thousands of
projections for thousands of different
jobs and I can't tell you which one to
use you know in datums it's easy find
the one that's the smallest one
projections aren't easy you have to find
the one that actually fits your data and
fits the story that you're trying to
tell let's take a letter straight this
we have here two different projections
on our bottom we've got good
old-fashioned Mercator that you
recognize from your elementary history
textbook map of the world on the top we
have nomic just a random other
projection we have these two lines in
Mercator we have this nice sweeping
Great Circle Route on a spherical earth
the shortest distance between two points
is a circle it's an art because the
planets arced anomic we have this big
flat line that goes straight across in
Mercator we have these points they are
evenly distributed every 5 degrees these
are the exact same wine those points are
the exact same points that point up
there with the arrow that's the same
point as the point down here with an
arrow we're looking at the exact same
data but we're looking at it in a
completely different way because we're
looking at it with a different
projection we've changed the story and
that's why I can't tell you which ones
to use your projection could it
literally is your view of the world I'm
going to belabor this point it's really
important three different shape files
actually the exact same shape file
projected three different ways this is
the United States the lower 48 states
we've projected it three different ways
with the common point being Omaha
Nebraska it's centered on Warren Buffett
the three thirty projections you see
here unprojected latitude and longitude
I can't tell you how many times I've
seen this mistake made you take that
long data and you just draw it on the
map with like ggplot pixel 1732 that's
lat/long 1732 don't do that it's bad it
generates it's totally you're not
respecting your data you're really
really skewing it you see here Mercator
my good old-fashioned Mercator you can
see how Mercator is a little bit wider a
little bit higher up it than our
unprojected data we've taken it and
we're making all of our latitudes and
longitudes artificially at 90-degree
angles it's actually a really good
projection for plotting naval travel
travel by ships which makes sense that's
what it was invented for and finally we
have here Lambert conformal conic this
is a projection that's trying to and
somewhat succeeding in showing all of
these shapes and exactly the same scale
as each other but look how far off they
all are this is the same data exact same
data very different ways of looking at
it when you're looking playing with your
geo data you have to think about the way
you're actually showing it to your users
okay I'm gonna go quick because I'm
starting to run out of time here be
skeptical skeptical about locations so
remember these guys they're coming up a
really accurate data these guys can go
down to thousandths of an inch you ain't
getting that data you're getting much
worse data which is coming out of this
thing called the Global Positioning
System and GPS isn't just GPS there's
also the Russian GLONASS system in the
European Space Agency's Galileo China's
building a system India's building says
there's a plethora of these things the
skies are crowded and GPS satellite is
this thing it is a power system a
battery and antenna all of which service
these things this is a cesium atomic
clock and there's going to be two of
these in a GPS satellite there's also
going to be two rubidium atomic clocks
in there and when is in there there's a
gaseous form of cesium there's a laser
that laser is shooting through the
cesium that cesium is getting excited
and it's vibrating and it's vibrating at
a really really constant rate
and that it can easily be measured and
it's really really accurate we can get
down to millionths of a second and what
and reason we have for is that it's
accurate as those are they have to be
launched into space on top of an
18-story 400 ton pile of explodey
which makes them slightly less accurate
so for atomic clocks you have a
complicated weighted average of those
times those times are being broadcast
out by the antennas on these GPS
satellites and your cell phone your GPS
receiver it's listening for them and
through a process called trans I never
pronounce this right trans latter ation
not triangulation triangulation is in a
2d space this is existing in a 4d space
XYZ and time we can actually compare
spheres and where those spheres overlap
that's where you are you need a minimum
of four GPS satellites but you want as
many as possible
a quick digression when I was to work
for the National Park Service we
actually had a program that would tell
us when there would be as many GPS
satellites overhead that we could
connect to at a particular time to
record as accurate information as we
could get so if that mean meant that you
had to be out 12 miles from the nearest
road at 3 a.m. on a Sunday you got your
ass out 12 miles from the nearest road
at 3 a.m. on a Sunday to collect that
data so that's how GPS works now I'm
going to tell you a secret your phone
never uses GPS GPS you have it depends
on you standing still when I was out
there 3 a.m. I would have my GPS
receiver set up for hours so that would
get accurized you don't have that when
you're trying to figure out how to get
from York Street Station over to the
Brooklyn Navy are your phone figured out
where you are pretty much instantly it
cheated it actually was talking to the
cell phone towers using a system called
a GPS a GPS has a GPS receiver on a cell
phone tower that's that
that receiver its survey grade it's not
the crap that's in your phone it's
gigantic it has a dish that's feet
across it's not moving
it's literally bolted into the concrete
it knows where it is
with incredible accuracy and it's
broadcasting out a signal that your
cellphone is looking at your cell phone
gets cheated in other ways it might if
you're going faster than a certain speed
it's going to snap you to the newest
road you think that looks accurate no no
it could move you tens of meters it
could move you hundreds of meters which
creates a big problem for us at
distillery all we get is latitude and
longitude we have no quality measures we
have no ever bars we just get lat and
long so we have to build our own
classifiers to actually take just let
and long and figure out how accurate it
is we have four levels of Geo data
there's wrong you saw at the very
beginning with my transposed latitude
and longitude let's just forget about
that in numerous other ways you can
screw that up I have stories let's focus
on the good stuff there's hyperlocal
hyperlocal data is good within a couple
of meters this is your phone really
actually connecting to the GPS network
and you sitting still for a very long
time I can use this to generate insights
on like for instance a specific store a
big-box store or something
we have meso local which cleverly just
means in the middle meso local data is I
can't put you in a building but I can
put you in a zip code or a census tract
something that's you know a couple of
kilometers inside there's broad data
broad data that's usually centroids
you're in the centroid of New York City
which is in a Duane Reade just north of
City Hall by the way I've been there I'm
insane I'm a geographer what do you want
you might be in the center roid of New
York State
may be the centroid of the United States
or the world so we have all this
different data we've collected it
remember we have 80 billion pieces of
lat/long every day I can be picky about
throwing it out
in fact we throw out two-thirds of all
the data we collect
we are generating insights on this stuff
if we use crappy data to generate it we
generate crappy insights and nobody
wants to pay for that so we use a couple
filters to clean up our data the first
one is the manhole cover in the manhole
cover is best illustrated by this fine
Catalonian tradition when you get data
and just lat/longs coming in they look
really accurate they've got a lot of
decimal points in those decimal points
they correspond to really accurate
locations on the earth feet or inches
well the manhole cover cows that's all
it does we're working with 80 billion
things a day it can't be that
complicated so we count how many people
are at this exact lat/long for a
particular time period and if it's more
than say five and we experimentally move
that up and down over time five as n we
say this point is not hyperlocal this is
a good data this is this is not not not
stuff that we want to be building out
good information on this is the most
metropolitan place in the United States
of America this box right here at any
one time there are thousands of people
standing on their shoulders at that
exact point this is the geographic
centroid of the lower 48 states and it's
in the middle of nowhere and our system
if you look at the manhole cover
thousands of people here you're not
there your sister your your phone for
whatever reason is saying I'm in America
that's all you get
it could because you have privacy
settings it could because your battery's
going low and your phone's cheating and
doesn't want to actually figure out it
where you are it could be because
remember a programmatic advertising
company ads that have location data
attached to them are considered more
valuable than ads that don't have any
information attached to them your app
developer has an incentive to send us
crap sorry
use my language it's what it is this oh
by the way great story here the people
who live over here kept getting visited
by people who are looking for their Max
or for their iPhones because they were
located to this
they actually sued it had the scented
Geographic centroid of the United States
moved a couple of kilometers that way in
the middle of the lake to prevent people
from showing up there totally true
I I've been intending by the way to just
drive past here just to visit anyway the
busiest place on planet Earth is right
here we call it Knoll island and the
geography world by the way I just
remembered I had a laser pointer and
Knoll Island they were according to our
system there are tens of thousands of
people there at any particular moment
this is what no and that's why I wasn't
using this thing Island looks like it's
actually this it's a piratical II use it
for predicting hurricanes hiding behind
where it says Atlas is about a hundred
thousand people at any particular second
so this whole set network of Geo's they
fall this is what this is one particular
app this is organic data that we're
getting in it looks really really good
right maybe it is but this is the
manhole covers look like hidden in that
data you could see they make a for a
pattern across the earth we call this
the grid because we're really clever
about naming things they are in a very
very regular pattern we've used four
year transforms on this data to be able
to find all the other points in the grid
we know every point on the grid on the
planet Earth and we know that if you
show up over those places you're not
actually there might be inside of a
Walmart you're not in that Walmart
you're kilometres away from it don't use
this for good insights the last filter
well not the last filter but the last
one I'm allowed to talk about is my
favorite we called the Superman filter
this is real data this is the most
egregious example I could find in our
data this is one device traveling across
the period of a day so the Superman
filter it's very simple rule if you
break the speed of sound between two
observations you are not actually real
it's super simple and you would be
amazed how many bad actors it catches
you don't need to have really
complicated sophisticated filtering this
these these three filters kick out
two-thirds of all the data
eighty billion points are collecting to
get us the good data I'm gonna finish up
really fast cuz I may have a few moments
use the right tool for the job would
you've collected this data we've treated
it right with the datums review
projected it right that detected that we
actually have to generate insights from
it so when I started at distillery we
only had one system and it was called
Uncle Jesse not that Uncle Jesse that
Uncle Jesse we're called distillery he
was a moonshiner I didn't name it it's
not my fault
Uncle Jesse is a PR tree you've been
waiting for me to get to get the data
structures haven't you it's a PR tree
and a PR tree a priority our tree is
basically espacially a bit spatially
aware tree the items to one side up to
the left side of this data structure to
our to the west the items to the right
to the right side are to the east every
step of this tree we prioritize we
basically figure out what are the
closest points using KN N and we say
these are the ones that are the child's
of these level of the the children of
this level of the tree and we keep
walking down it's really fast we have
millions and millions of points of
interest inside this database and we get
single-digit millisecond return times
and the reason we do that is that it
lives in memory you can see where the
problem is we have lots and lots of
places that were interested in because
we evolved from just a programmatic
company and your company also does
insights that meant that this was
getting really really big we can only
have so much space that we can put on
our machines that we can look at him
live so we had to sit down and say how
do we actually do both fast look ups and
really really good insights and the
answer was we built a second GIS I know
that that violates computer thought that
you build one system and you keep using
it but by using two different systems
we actually got we real flexibility in
speed our second system I keep
forgetting that doesn't work
good job staples is called geo tiles and
geo tiles is a tessellating grid
of 100 meter by 100 meter boxes that
spread across the entire earth every box
has a unique identifier and the
algorithm that we used to generate those
identifiers is the reversible I can take
a lat long convert it directly into an
identifier in fact that's the last thing
that uncle Jessie does before it passes
off to other parts of our programming it
generates this ID I can take that ID and
turn it back into a lot long and it
anonymizes your location I don't know
exactly where you are in this this is a
cartoon by the way this isn't real data
and this would be a cartoon of a census
track in Greenpoint Brooklyn so here's a
grid point that point is mapped to this
polygon this census tract but it can be
mapped to almost anything it also
belongs to a polygon that is the ZIP
code in this area it's mapped to a
polygon that is Brooklyn it's mapped to
a polygon that is the city of New York
it's a map to the polygon of New York
State I can map it to any kind of
insight generating thing I want think of
it this way it belongs to the Crown
lands it belongs to the Kings Kings
Landing DMA I was given a bet that if I
would use this or not
it belongs to the castle the Geo we have
two systems one collects things really
really fast one lets us go in after the
fact after data is in our datastore with
this geo tiles ID and generate lots and
lots of data from it so six six tips
spatial data is different it's special
you have to know about it you have to
know about how it was collected
what datum was it in how was it what
what scaled it was the data you have to
think about how to visualize it how is
going to be projected and what the
different uses of all those different
projections are hint hire a geographer
you have to be skeptical about your
location data because your GPS or
whatever you're using it's lying to you
in very subtle ways you can be picky
when you have lots and lots of data it's
okay to throw out lots and lots of data
to just find the best stuff and use the
right tool for the job it's okay to
build multiple systems that do similar
jobs or even the same job
that you can optimize for speed and look
up my name is Peter Lenz I have a broken
clicker I am a senior geospatial analyst
at distillery I'm over my time but I'm
very interested in any questions you
guys have yeah what causes the Superman
effect if the device is flying around
the earth so there's two things going on
there first one is just plain fraud
remember how I said that that
advertisements the bid requests that
have location data are more valuable
people lie about the exact location
maybe you're in Hollywood
Callie Wood Florida but they say that
you're in Hollywood California because a
person who is be located there
presumably would be in some kind of
luxury segment be worth more money the
other thing is just your GPS going nuts
GPS can cache location data the number
of times that you see things like
someone getting on a plane in New York
and it's still pretty sending out that
that location when you got off a plane
in Los Angeles you'll see a lot of that
stuff and then of course there's just
junk there's a lot of junky data out
there what about continental drift how
does that affect your calculations it
actually does believe it or not for
instance the Adirondack Mountain is just
a couple hundred miles from us that is
actually growing at a rate of about a
centimeter a year in height and that's
glacial rebound that's actually not like
continental drift that's the earth is
still bouncing back from the end of the
LAT the weight of the ice sheet from the
last ice age 10,000 years ago we're
still recovering from that that's the
great thing about geography it's way
bigger than any of us no matter what you
think you are how important you are
geography is bigger and it's got bigger
things and bigger numbers it's cool sexy
that give you a serious answer we have
to actually update our datums every
couple of decades because things are
moving around leap seconds which you
also hear about that's the same thing
for the GPS
we're actually correcting every time
there's a major earthquake the earth
actually slows its rotation slightly
people don't think about this but the
Fukushima earthquake actually made us do
a leap second a couple years ago that
affected all my systems and made them
less accurate until we were to update
for it yes we have to think about that
do you do you have a process for
figuring out whether or not you're
throwing out too much data so that is
the art side of data science there's no
ground truth about what good data is the
proof is kind of in the pudding we
generate insights and we share them with
our clients and independently they have
systems that are generating very similar
insights the fact that we have two
separate systems that are generating a
lot of the same data that suggests that
we're getting a good good good amount of
data there just isn't some formula that
I can say this is the exact amount of
data I should be throwing out I can look
into it and say this this doesn't pass
the smell test this looks funny this is
a grid why do we have this it's the art
side of data science and there's no way
to quantify it
the phones are using Wi-Fi to detect
where people are right now and how how
accurate do you consider this GPS
information based on the Wi-Fi network
so yes phones actually have a hierarchy
of different systems that they use to
locate yourself GPS is at the bottom of
it because it uses a lot of power to
listen to those GPS satellites which
have weak signals sitting up there
20,000 kilometers above us a GPS uses
power and then you can look at SSIDs and
this is Google Street View is driving
around it's taking pictures it's also
snarfing up Wi-Fi names and yourself
when you connect to Google Maps or Apple
does the same thing and lots of other
companies do the same thing they're
actually passing on the SSID s of the
Wi-Fi networks that you are near and
they are saying we're in our database
did we see these unique names this is
your location
it's a cheating way I never even have to
go and look at any kind of spatial
information I don't have to look at GPS
or anything
um it can be good in a place like a city
it depends entirely on how old the data
is you know there's places where Street
View hasn't been in five years
it's gonna be really bad in a place
that's a city like this where they go
all the time it can be good we don't
actually know when we're getting that
data we have no idea what the source is
I would love to do that experiment and
find out I can't yeah
funny story and because it was a Holly
Inn it mapped me to another hotel in
Malaga which has the same Wi-Fi name yep
that happens all the time I used to work
for the National Park Service we had a
Wi-Fi name there specified by government
IT people and they're the same in every
single Park it would regularly locate me
in Fort Collins Colorado I worked in
Yosemite in California in the Sierras
but they would put me in Colorado I
cannot tell you the number of times I
saw an ad for this particular Colorado
tile company who are trying to get me to
visit because I was a local customer
not-not-not really yeah that's totally
the thing I would love to do that
experiment okay a last question
[Music]
what kind of databases do you guys is so
most of our data is in Hadoop we we
actually have a gigantic could do
cluster that that's most of that 20
petabytes we also have online live
geospatial things that we're running
those live in Postgres that we use for
for display none of our back-end is
actually in that only displays in
Postgres our back-end systems are either
that PR tree I showed the Geo tile
system which is just an ID ID basically
that gives a key key value store
Cassandra or it goes into hive we love
hive we were actually one of the first
users of hive and I love it great thank
you very much